if you're following the elections and
you're overwhelmed by the electoral map
don't worry because we can actually
focus on just a handful
of what are called battleground states
there are a number of them
but here are our top picks arizona
florida michigan minnesota wisconsin
texas and pennsylvania so why are they
called battlegrounds
and why are they important most states
tend to vote republican or democrat
but some states while they have a
history of swinging either way
or maybe they have a diverse range of
voters over here where the city part of
scranton is
everybody's for biden but once you go
out maybe 10 15 minutes towards the
farms
a lot of trump supporters over there
pennsylvania is actually joe biden's
home state voters there backed barack
obama in 2012
but in 2016 it swung for trump
wisconsin's another one
it was the big surprise of 2016.
wisconsin hadn't voted republican since
1984.
clinton didn't even campaign there and
trump ended up winning by just 23 000
votes
and there are others arizona is a
question mark this year because
while it's reliably republican in the
recent midterm elections
a democrat won the senate race there
then there's florida
it's got 29 electoral votes and it's
fickle
i really do believe that biden's going
to win
the last three and a half years have
been horrible we will accept whatever
trump is
better a jerk than a communist
michigan is another battleground both
biden and trump campaigned there this
year
and in 2016 trump beat clinton there by
just over 10 000 votes
minnesota usually leans democrat but it
could still swing in the 2018
congressional elections
minnesota's seat was one of the only
ones to flip from democrat to republican
but perhaps the most interesting
potential toss-up this year
is texas
[Applause]
[Music]
a democrat hasn't won there since the
70s
so republicans could generally relax
knowing the state's 38 electors would go
to them
but the electorate in texas has changed
a lot cities are growing it's got the
second
highest hispanic population after
california and they lead democrat
[Applause]
now by the end of october most polls had
biden in the lead in nearly all of those
battleground states
but both candidates need to win most if
not all of them
if they want to get anywhere near close
to winning the electoral college
and with it the presidency start here
we'll have regular updates throughout
the election night to help you
understand what's going on
look for us on facebook instagram and
twitter